[Musique]
il
docteur philippe charlier bonjour
bonjour merci d'être présent sur le
plateau de tv 78 pour ce vide qui vous
est entièrement consacré vous êtes très
connu pour ceux qui ne vous connaissent
pas encore
on voit quand même vous présentait donc
vous êtes évidemment médecins en
médecine légale vous m'arrêtez quand je
dis une bêtise d'accord vous êtes
présent sur le magazine de la santé sur
france 5
oui un jour par semaine j'ai choisi
semaine le mercredi
le mercredi jour des enfants très bien
vous êtes beaucoup de choses vous êtes
anthropologue
vous n'êtes pas les aux pathologistes en
fait c'est un médecin légiste qui
s'intéresse aux restes humains anciens
fouilles archéologiques principalement
des pouilles historique reliques
or vous donner aussi des cours à la
faculté de médecine de versailles saint
quentin
oui à l'ufr de sciences de la santé
exactement voilà vous êtes venu donc on
voisins vous êtes aussi auteur et c'est
ce qui nous intéresse principalement
vous avez écrit près d'une vingtaine de
livres quelquefois d'ailleurs co écrit
je sais pas comment fonctionner avec
david alliot c'est un ami donc voilà on
un ami on a pour vocation tous les deux
de faire sortir la science de
laboratoire donc du coup transformé si
on peut dire
des données qui sont un peu un peu
difficile à comprendre un des articles
scientifiques en quelque chose de clair
compréhensible et potentiellement
amusant et vous aimez faire partager vos
connaissances et votre savoir la preuve
en est ces légers déménager la
bibliothèque
voilà donc pas mal de livres
et bah écoute et l'avant dernier chez
tallandier s'appelle quand la science
explore l'histoire
voilà donc vous explorez différents cas
historique en face janvier ce sont des
patients historiques qui sont étudiées
avec un oeil médical ou anthropologique
en gros on apprend un tout petit peu
comment on peut faire une sorte de
consultations médicales sur des crânes
sur des squelettes sur des têtes
réduites sur des momies qu'elle soit
égyptiennes qu'elles soient péruvienne
ou qu'il s'agisse de véritables
personnages historiques pour lesquelles
on a encore un nom comme je peigne
israël diane de poitiers et richard
coeur de lion
voilà des écrits ou des portraits vous
avez raison concrète
oui on travaille aussi quand on n'a pas
la chance d'avoir les restes humains on
peut aussi travailler sur des dossiers
médicaux sur des radiographies des
masques mortuaires et même des peintures
qui nous représente imaginer qu'on est
plus votre corps dans mille ans mais
qu'on a une peinture qui vous représente
eh bien on pourra re compte
situé la couleur de vos yeux la
pigmentation de votre peau etc d'accord
et j'ai oublié de dire que finalement au
départ je crois que vous vouliez être
archéologue
oui je voulais être archéologue
finalement j'ai réussi à tenir log
mais j'ai passé je suis passé par
médecine entre temps voilà voilà
et j'ai la peau vous avez vraiment le
goût du mystère enfin de la résolution
des mystères jeanne sol c'est ce qui
vous anime et que finalement vous êtes
donné des moyens extrêmement pointus
pour y arriver
des fois on a du mal à choisir entre les
sciences humaines et les sciences
fondamentales et sciences molles et les
sciences dures comme les appellent
certains moi j'ai choisi de faire les
deux et je trouve que les deux
cohabitent très bien oui c'est pas un
sens du mystère c'est un sens de la
résolution des énigmes
oui mais ça c'est à cause de tous les
médecins et a fortiori de médecins
légistes
oui effectivement et du coup vous avez
écrit donc où de nombreux livres et le
second enfin le tout frais le les
derniers je veux dire j'ai pas du tout
est frais - et non à la autopsies des
monstres célèbres qui nous raconte
pareil des autres patients d'autres
patients à l'argent des autres en
patience sont heatley par exemple lucie
chopin des cartes saint louis voilà
autant de patients qui sont passés dans
les mains de mon équipe et moi même et
on a pu à chaque fois essayé de les
sortir non pas de l'anonymat il n'était
pas anodine mais sortir soit des erreurs
historiques soit sortir des causes de
mort qui étaient méconnus ou
on apprendre plus sur leur intimité pas
une autorité croquignol est une intimité
qui menèrent mais on n'est pas du tout
dans people plutôt une intimité qui nous
les rend plus proche voilà plus humain
plus moins de dix tentèrent c'est pas
juste une peinture ou une sculpture
qu'on va dans un musée ce sont des
personnages qui prennent cher grâce à la
médecine et à l'anthropologie d'accord
il ya quelques exemples bon moi je suis
concerné un peu par par versailles à la
cour il ya eu une épidémie d'avc par à
l'époque on disait pas à baisser de deux
courtisans qui meurt dans la fleur de
l'âge de passe de façon complètement
inexpliqué donc ça c'était un une source
d'un trig que vous avez donc expliquez
vous il faisait ce qu'on appelait des
attaques d'apoplexie en gros pour nous
ce sont des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux
pourquoi parce qu'ils n'ont j'ai trop il
n'avait absolument aucune activité
physique il n'avait il était bourré de
stress comme beaucoup de courtisans qui
devait absolument ne pas tomber en
disgrâce musée leur place ils roi ou
d'autres et puis dans des conditions qui
était seul le roi était relativement
bien chauffé bien nourris et bien mais
les conditions pour le reste c'était un
château qui étaient très mal logées des
dépendances qui était pas
particulièrement adéquate pour une
survie prolongée donc on est on est
retombé sur un livre qu'on a analysées
avec un oeil neuf qui était une sorte de
traité de mort non naturelle
écrite par dionis un chirurgien de
l'époque et c'est assez bien documenté
très bien précis et du coup ça nous
permet de faire des diagnostics 200
voire 300 en plus de la science actuelle
d'accord donc en fait ils mourraient oui
d'une hygiène de vie déplorables à
déplorable des repas gargantuesque alors
on se dit toujours oui mais ils peuvent
en prendre une toute petite quantité oui
mais même si on prend une toute petite
quantité de make his duties en sauce
alors déjà beaucoup de choses mais en
sauce plein de grâce et sans activité
physique avec l'apparition du tabac qui
n'a pas de filtre à l'époque qu'on va
fumer ou chiquer des activités physiques
qui sont à la limite d'une mais en
rajoute cool rajouter du stress
là-dessus rajouter des sexes masculins
qui sont un facteur de risque
cardiovasculaire oui forcément sénat oui
c'était beaucoup plus si on fait pas de
l'infarctus en fait
enfin un accident vasculaire d'accord et
un peu nos même style on à balzac
d'ailleurs qui meurt très jeune vous
expliquer à 51 ans
finalement c'est pas que la mortalité
était plus plus rapide à l'époque que ça
c'est juste qu'ils avaient pareilles
circonstances a fait consommer beaucoup
de ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur de ce petit
gobelet de café en l'occurrence qui
était bien plus dosée que maintenant le
café machine qu'on peut avoir
il n'en consommait pas deux trois ou dix
par jour mais quasiment une trentaine ce
qui est assez délétère sur le plan
cardiaque mais pour le reste de
l'organisme
sans compter toutes ses insomnies sans
compter son rythme de travail acharné
son embonpoint et autres donc oui le
pauvre balzac qui était un génie absolu
un homme aimant en plus auprès de madame
dans ce cas bien malheureusement à la
mouscane n'a pas beaucoup profité hyper
stressée puis ses créanciers avaient
fait installer vous savez la connaissez
la légende une une porte à l'arrière de
son habitation poursuivre les créanciers
etc
il fait semblant de ne pas être à
domicile on connaît tous ces histoires
racontées de génération en génération
nous on s'intéresse non pas des
histoires à une réalité biologique
c'était que je n'avais pas du tout et
que à 51 ans il partit la haute île
réputée tisane au tilleul on aura
peut-être eu deux fois plus de comédie
humaine c'est dommage
alors bon il ya plein plein de kayes
père intéressant donc dans ce livre on
voit la couverture à l'écran et moi j'ai
remarqué de deux études d'alert que vous
nous donnez vous parlez des du
réchauffement climatique
oui vous déconseillé d'aller farfouiller
dans le grand nord des vieux restes
d'ossements parce que pourrait y avoir
une pandémie ou pourraient avoir des
virus réchauffer mais si j'ai bien
compris vous avez bien compris c'est
alors tel que vous le présenter ça
ressemble un peu à un scénario
catastrophe sur hollywood c'est
exactement ça néanmoins il faut être un
tout petit peu de fruits dans le
permafrost dire le père j seul comme on
dit souvent cette couche de sol
congolais au scrabble certains démons
pas mal de points le pergélisol se font
au fur et à mesure à cause du
réchauffement climatique un couche de
sol qui est congelé depuis plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'années
malheureusement en ce moment ça
disparaît et ça libère toutes les
substances organiques merci minérale qui
étaient stockés là dedans du mercure
mais également des virus des bactéries
des parasites etc
parce que les végétaux étaient
congeler tout simplement les restes de
les restes animaux s'étaient endormis
ont dit cui et sans voix c'était la
deuxième place finale et du coup tout
ceci se retrouve libéré soit dans des
petits cours d'eau soit sous la semelle
des gens qui ont voyagé
il ya un vrai danger potentiel à ramener
ceux ci des épidémies locales ont déjà
reçu rhji des épidémies de charbon chez
des reines mais aussi chez des humains
donc il ya un vrai danger il faut
réglementer un tout petit peu tout ceci
c'est simplement pour vous montrer que
travailler sur des restes humains qu'ils
aient plusieurs millions d'années comme
lucie là ça va c'est de la pierre quand
on travaille sur des restes qui ont
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'années
oui c'est encore quand c'était congelés
potentiellement dangereux et c'est pas
anodin de travailler sur des choses
pareilles d'accord bon d'écouter tenoux
le comme on dit c'est entendu nous en
cours que nous le pour dit voilà je
comptais pas y aller de tout les ans
après il ya un deuxième sujet que vous
abordé à travers ces cas c'est le sujet
des cancers oui vous dites qu'il y en
avait beaucoup déjà parce que vous en
fait on a présenté une histoire un peu
de la santé humaine quoi de la
préhistoire à presque nos jours dans sa
hausse entre ce livre en seniors soigner
de façon parfois très étrange mais ce
qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a et donc par
exemple vous prenez le cas du cancer
d'anne d'autriche
oui on s'imagine toujours que les
cancers n'existait pas avant la
révolution industrielle c'est à dire
1860 à peu près en france et est que ce
sont les peaux le mans industriels qui
ont favorisé l'apparition du cancer
à l'époque moderne c'est totalement faux
on se rend compte en étudiant des momies
des squelettes même des crémations de
grecque ou romaine des quelques siècles
avant avant jésus-christ et bien on se
rend compte que non déjà des cancers de
la prostate du sein du foie du sang
leucémies ou lymphome existait déjà à
ces périodes là et qu'ils ont laissé une
trace
sauf que l'épaulement était différent ce
n'étaient pas les mêmes que maintenant
c'était d'autres substances chimiques
qu'ils pouvaient être environnementale
elle se trouvait sur place parce que il
ya des terres qui sont un peu
radioactive parce que il ya des terres
qui sont riche en arsenic en plomb en
mercure en antimoine comme par exemple à
comps pays
ou alors on se rend compte que non
c'était parce que des gens travailler le
bois d
des espèces aromatiques que ça crée une
inflammation chronique au niveau du nez
sur laquelle ensuite s'ils vont faire
des cancers c'est intéressant parce que
ça renverse complètement des tendances
qu'on établisse des idées fausses
exactement et puis c'est nous renseigne
aussi sur comment certains personnages
historiques étaient traités vous faisait
référence à anne d'autriche la pauvre
anne d'autriche donc la femme de louis
xiii qui a développé par louis xiv qui a
développé malheureusement un cancer du
sein et à l'époque on considérait que le
cancer était une sorte de petit parasite
d'un monstre qui grignotaient le corps
le crabe exactement le temps que c'était
plutôt cancer s'est inspiré d'un mot qui
vient de crevettes tout simplement donc
une petite crevette qui grossit
malheureusement et qui va boulotter
littéralement l'organisme humain et donc
on extirpe pas le cancer au départ on
incise est le cancer c'est ce qu'a eue
la pauvre anne d'autriche et en lui
mettait de la nourriture on lui mettait
de la viande viande de porc viande de
cheval viande de boeuf ou pour essayer
de trouver quelle était la viande au
goût du cancer et pour qu'il mange la
viande plutôt que manger l'organisme
j'ai tourner son appétit veine autre
chose on nourrissait le cancer ça
évidemment ça ne marchait pas
malheureusement et du coup elle a été
amputée amputé de son sein de la tumeur
est allé de l'autre côté je vous fais
pas le câblo il est dramatique
elle a eu un comportement exemplaire
jusqu'à la fin et alors on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya autant de cancer ou
quand même plus on a envie de dire d'eux
n'a peut-être plus et en plus de
différents voulait il y en a pas
beaucoup plus nous la rejetons court
quand même ok donc ça c'est dit autopsy
dément célèbre donc bah écoutez c'est
juste passionnant alors maintenant on va
passer un autre livre s'appelle sont bi
ou alors voilà sambi il a quelques
années ce livre quand il est sorti en
2015 mais en revanche il vient de sortir
un livre de poche chez les enfants qu'il
a une actu et il est prêt il a inspiré
une bande dessinée collection la
bédéthèque des savoirs chez lombard
on vous a mis en relation avec un
dessinateur richard guérineau et moi
tellement et voilà alors vous dites ces
deux livres se complète l'est de l'île
se complètent ces pâles l'introduction
en bd de voilà c'est pas une
illustration du livre c'est vraiment
deux choses différentes parce qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'informations comme
vous l'avez dit moi je suis médecin
légiste et archéo anthropologue et je
m'intéresse notamment aux rituels magico
religieux autour de la maladie et de la
mort c'est pour ça que je suis en poste
actuellement comme directeur de la
recherche au musée du quai branly parce
qu'on utilise cette technique médicales
et médico légal pour expliquer soit des
phénomènes soit des objets
principalement des objets de musée et je
me suis intéressé en haïti aux zombies
c'est à dire les noms des autres musées
tâter les normes iso n'diaye bah vous
savez les zombies c'est vraiment à la
confluence entre la médecine et
d'anthropologie je pense que c'est
l'archétype même de cette confluence
c'est pas les envies de pacotille on
voit qu'il faut avant tout il faut
différencier deux sortes de zombies vous
avez des zombies haut débit avec un e
qui viennent des états unis qui sont
dans l'imaginaire collectif américain
will the walking dead ou la nuit des
morts-vivants dormir dans les années 60
pensent que puisque très marrant ne sont
pas du tout une réalité at elle ajouté
en fait c'est les zombies de télégénique
si on peut dire c'est le fantasme de la
mort contagieuse voilà s'exclame et
bancaires c'est un peu comme les
vampires exact mais comme c'est à
l'opposé de ce qui est vraiment le
vampire est le peuple le deuil de ce
qu'est vraiment envie d'aller au fond de
vous vous êtes intéressé aux vrais
zombies
je suis allé sur place tu m'en sers et
enquêtes j'en ai rencontré quelques-uns
heureusement donc rencontré des zombies
qui en fait s'en sont sortis tout
simplement parce que comme si on sort
pas il n'y a pas trop moyen de l'est de
les rencontrer une source
lors d'un dernier voyage où j'ai pu en
voir qui travaillaient dans les champs
de canne à sucre mais aujourd'hui on
parle de jeu en fait qu'ils ont été
exclus volontairement par la société ils
ont été mis en morceaux sociale parce
qu'on considérait qu'il faisait du mal
pour la société la justice cette justice
parallèle pour les violeurs les voleurs
les capteurs d'héritage les assassins
des gens qui font du mal mais aussi
parfois des gens comme vous et moi
d'autant de cette roche qui ne faisons
pas le mal mais en ont pas qui dérange
mais qui
sont empoisonnés par quelqu'un de leur
entourage par exemple quelqu'un qui ne
voudraient du mal va nous on biffe ye
brave à nous empoisonner donc ça prend
un certain temps vous donnez l'exemple
d'un médecin qui avait passé la
toxicomanie s'appelle ce module est trop
d'eau toxines
voilà qui vient du poisson fugu voilà au
japon fufu en haïti et peut-être aux
dons pour le zoologue voilà donc ce
poison vient de là et j'ai si j'ai bien
compris pour obliger quelqu'un alors on
met un petit peu de cette poudre
toxiques
là c'est un médecin on lui mettait sur
ses accoudoirs donc tous les jours le
pauvre homme était comme ça à poser et
au bout d'un moment ça finit par
l'empoisonner poblete moi c'est devenu
un légume à savoir la zombie en résumé
un peu ça exactement voilà après le
zombie une fois qu'ils les zombies fier
pour surtout pas lui donner de sel tout
à fait signer en ligne ont fait sortir
de ces conditions sa condition et en
fait il reprend son libre arbitre et
reprend sa conscience le mot légumes que
vous avez utilisé bon je sais c'est ça
mais il est un peu on va éviter
d'utiliser ce n'est pas super sympa
en fait ce sont des gens qui sont
drogués tout simplement il sont drogués
ils perdent leur libre arbitre ils sont
capables uniquement de faire des gestes
stéréotypé travailler à l'usiné
travailler dans les champs de canne à
sucre ou dans les rizières
je vais faire le ménage s'occuper des
enfants de façon très sommaire mais pas
n'importe quel enfant les enfants des
sorciers qui les ont douze mois qui est
des beaux corps exactement et c'est vrai
que parfois on quand on prend la voiture
sur les chemins détournés dans une
plaine en haïti que la plaine de
l'artibonite on voit ce type de
personnes dans les champs de canne à
sucre ou deux
dans les rizières mais comme c'est juste
un peu frais en main et alors vous
raconter que lors du tremblement de
terre de 2010 en haïti
certains en guise se sont trompés dire
échapper en fait leurs maîtres sont
morts écrasés dans les maisons ou dans
d'autres circonstances et du coup ils
ont bien dû se nourrir et donc il en
mangeait des choses dont certaines
étaient sales et donc du coup ils ont
sorti un peu de ce cercle infernal
ou alors comme leur maître était mort il
ne pouvait plus leur donner les
barbituriques où les plages audoises
hippiques ils prenaient tous les jours
et les effets du médicament se sont
dissipés au fur et à mesure c'est ça
parce que une fois que vous êtes bien
empoisonné bien on dit fier il faut tout
de même vous donner régulièrement des
produits pour rester dans cet état là
oui si on arrête tous les produits
vous reprenez vous redonnez l'air comme
l avait vient de sa gueule quand même
une petite statistique est d'accord et
est ce que vous dites que c'est une
façon de rendre la justice parallèle
mais est-ce que c'est pas aussi une
façon de soigner pas soigné mais de dak
hulk est pas inculquer une camisole
chimique pour les malades psychiques
quelque part non généralement on
n'annonce généralement les noms des
sociétés secrètes bison gauche emploi le
cochon grillé cochon marron qui organise
la zombification lorsque la personne à
des troubles psychiatriques qu'elle est
folle entre villages alors d'être
ambitieux on ne peut pas être modifiée
si on est fou complètement vision bi
fier que quelqu'un de sain et disent non
et vous savez en france donc on a la
première instance ensuite on peut faire
appel devant le tribunal et ensuite on
la cour de cassation et éventuellement
ça fait trois instances avant d'être
ambitieux en haïti on a cet avis oui on
vous prévient cet falloir cette fois est
donc cette fois vous avez là vous êtes
convoqué en pleine forêt dans un champ
de canne à sucre avec une table dressée
des fétiches et autres et on vous
explique tu arrêtes de faire le mal
sinon il va t'arriver une peine pire que
la mort la modification
cette fois de suite et donc il faut
persister et signer cette fois de suite
pour être remboursé quand c'est bien
organisé pour les violeurs les capteurs
d'héritage etc en revanche quand c'est
des zombies de droit commun entre
guillemets comme vous et moi
par exemple une belle-mère qui
empoisonnent son gendre c'est ce médecin
géologie ou sa belle fille dans ce cas
la cia même pas de convocations ou autre
chose direct c'est ce qu'on appelle les
amplifie cassions criminels et les
autres sont des amplifications juridique
ok d'accord bon et donc ça existe
toujours as existe toujours il y en a
une par semaine à peu près en haïti qui
fait les qui fait les gros titres dans
le journal local qu'on appelle le
nouvelliste qui est l'équivalent du
parisien
vous dites à la fin dit que vous aviez y
retournez vous êtes retourné je suis
retourné déjà une fois et puis j'y
retourne encore parce que c'est un
d'abord j'adore passionnément l'île
d'haïti pour lesquelles j'aime beaucoup
d'amitié et puis en plus c'est un
terrain d'investigation anthropologique
fascinant là j'y vais maintenant avec ma
casquette de musée du quai branly donc
alors justement musée du quai branly
parlons-en
oui alors dont je vous parle juste de
cette bd qui est qui complète bien votre
livre voilà on est d'accord
ensuite donc qu'est bon lit ça veut dire
quoi c'est votre avenir ça si vos
prochains transport phase actuelle c'est
mon présent c'est votre présence et
votre l'avenir parce que vous travaillez
sur les fétiches sont mis au travail
en fait la direction de la recherche a
en charge d'organiser la recherche mais
aussi l'enseignement les colloques les
cours etc et on a développé un programme
de recherche qui s'appelle archéologie
du surnaturel ou le musée du quai branly
va avec les autorités locales mener des
recherches archéologiques en équateur en
haïti au bénin au cameroun est encore
ailleurs dans le monde
ce sont des recherches à la fois
archéologiques et anthropologique le but
c'est que les objets qui sont conservés
au musée du quai branly ses statuts ces
textiles ces armes parfois ces objets du
quotidien
eh bien on les remettent dans leur
contexte qui est un contexte d'origine
un temple hill maison un lieu de culte
et d'essayer de mieux les comprendre en
lien avec les cultures d'origine où
c'est vraiment un travail en commun
entre le musée du quai branly et des
instituts de recherche de patrimoine de
ces différents pays où main dans la main
on travaille à mieux comprendre ses
moyens d'organiser le chaos si on peut
dire c'est à dire ses moyens de dominer
un peu le lendemain le l'avenir le
moment où tu reviendras la mort et la
lutte contre l'inconnu en général
d'accord et je me disais cote quand on
lit vous lire on se dit mais les
médecins à l'époque qui remonte mais
très très longtemps avait des façons
abracadabrantesque de soigner on l'avion
pour tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
pensez que mettons dans 200 ans
les médecins dans 200 dans vont trouver
que nous aujourd'hui
enfin vous surtout à vous soigner les
gens de façon complètement hallucinant
c'est certainement certaines est
certainement fait certainement des
erreurs méthodologiques vous savez j'ai
41 ans maintenant j'ai commencé mais
sinon ça commence à faire un bon bout de
temps
vingt ans au moins et déjà je me rends
compte maintenant qu'on soigne des
patients maintenant de façon opposée à
quand j'ai commencé ma maison
oui mais c'est vraiment ne serait-ce que
la position dans laquelle on pose les
enfants le soir les bébés dans leurs
listes pour prévenir les morts subites
d'une émission au début quand j'ai
commencé la médecine il fallait de
coucher sur le ventre maintenant on est
couché sur le dos donc on est à 180
degrés rien que sur ce tout petit détail
imaginez maintenant sur des prises de
médicaments de toxiques des prises en
charge
oui il est vraisemblable vous savez là
la médecine change très vite elle évolue
en fonction du temps en fonction des
populations en fonction de l'homme
lui-même qui évolue aussi donc c'est
bien mais c'est bien donc les fétiches
finalement ils ont quelque chose
d'humain canton j'imagine une fois je
pense aux poupées vaudou par exemple
dont les poupées vaudou donc ces poupées
qui du vaudou haïtien où l on oui elles
ont même quelque chose de très humain
ils ont même des portions du main à
l'intérieur des cheveux des poils que le
beau corps ce sorcier dont on va payer
pour aller les chercher dans votre lit
dans votre vol est notre salle de
montfavet la blonde le truc qu'on
n'avait jamais avec des cheveux de poil
ça c'est pourquoi je suis pas allé seul
ou encore pour vafc est donc ce genre de
choses là c'est ou des boutons de
chemise ou un fusil abadie mais ma part
je devrais je note devant vous à papier
avec votre écriture on peut récupérer sa
lé maître dans une poupée vaudou pour
faire j'aimerais bien faire du mal ou
jeter un sort amoureux autre chose donc
oui ça c'est possible mais même les
fétiches où un mot qu'on n'utilise pas
trop en le mot fétiche de
l'anthropologie on n'aime pas trop car
c'est plutôt malveillants on va dire les
statuts de culte où les statues en
général en afrique subsaharienne donc
bénin cameroun république démocratique
du congo au burkina faso par exemple
quand on dit qu'elles sont animés on se
rend compte maintenant quand on en fait
un scanner médical que oui à l'intérieur
et sont creusées vous voyez l'extérieur
belle sculpture mais c'est parfois
habillés et avec un trou au niveau de la
bouche au niveau des oreilles au niveau
du nez vous dites c'est normal ben oui
mais en fait c'est true ces cavités vont
plus loin à l'intérieur il ya aussi un
tube digestif un estomac qui va jusqu'à
l'an belgique et qui descend ensuite
jusqu'à l'anus et quand on nourrit ses
statuts eh bien elle digère les
offrandes et les excrète un tout petit
peu plus tard il ya même encore plus on
fait couler de l'huile dessus lui il va
être absorbé par l'eau l'absorption tout
simplement un canton mais ensuite les
statuts en plein sommeil elle va
transpirer cette suite donc elle va
transpirer comme un humain
non seulement elle va digérer comme un
humain mais aussi transpirer comme un
humain donc quand on dit que ces statues
sont animées au sens de elles sont
vivantes elles sont anatomiquement en
effet comme un être vivant et ça c'est
parce qu'on fait des études médicales
sur ses fétiches entre guillemets sur
ces objets de musée qu'on les comprend
beaucoup mieux mais qu'on comprend aussi
les croyances des populations qui les
ont faites
et pour lesquelles une partie de ce
savoir avec la modernisation s'est perdu
et pour ça qu'on fait toujours ça en
lien avec ces populations
les descendants actuels là on va dire la
génération actuelle qui encore
détentrices d'un savoir et qui ne
demandent pas mieux que de reconstituer
ce savoir ancien perdu bon écoute et
très bien donc je sens que ça va faire
l'objet d'un nouveau livre où nous
deviner très bien exactement
si je vous dis à bientôt pour parler de
ce nouveau livre est là avec plaisir
pour merci c'est passionnant on pourrait
parler des heures mais le temps qui nous
est imparti est maintenant écoulé donc à
très vite docteur philippe charlier est
vraiment encore merci merci intéressant
c'est gentil
[Musique]